nach welchen kriterien legen wir jetzt
eigentlich fest wer zu portugal noch
hinzukommt und ab wann ist dann portugal
keine virus varianten gebiet mehr weil
wir delta längst haben und zwar in
gleicher größenordnung
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen dass
diese regeln finde ich sehr
unübersichtlich sind und es kommt ja
dazu so wurde es ja heute auch schon
gesagt vom bund wenn bei uns dann viel
delta variante ist dann ist das auch
irgendwie gar nicht mehr schlimm dass es
in portugal so vieles und dann wird es
wieder gelockert
ich finde dass es nicht gut
übersichtlich ist um es mal nett
auszudrücken was ich gerne möchte und
was der vorschlag von mecklenburg
vorpommern ist dass mindestens der
standard eingehalten wird den wir im
letzten jahr hatten und da war es so
dass man eben danach guckt was ist ein
risikogebiet und wenn jemand aus einem
risikogebiet kommt dass er sich dann
wenigstens mit einem pcr-test testet ja
der ist es nur ein antigen schnelltest
wir alle wissen der held einen tag wenn
es gut läuft und dann war eigentlich die
regel fünf tage quarantäne und ein
zweiter test ich finde wenn man so was
grundsätzlich einführt so wie im letzten
jahr
gerade weil es ansteckender mutationen
gibt dann gibt es dafür auch eine
akzeptanz und ansonsten kann ich nur
sagen ich empfehle aus diesen gründen
mein bürgerinnen und bürgern eben nicht
diese reisen in andere länder weil es
genau so ist die reise nirgendwo einen
tag hin und nächsten tag ist es anders
ist holen sie neue regeln ein und ich
verstehe auch diesen frust und deswegen
kann ich nur empfehlen
in diesem jahr möglichst auf diese reise
noch zu verzichten
so wie es ja lindner ja auch eben
geschildert hat das geht sicherlich
nicht bei jeder reise das verstehe ich
wir hatten gerade urlaubsreisen kann man
am besten in deutschland machen und
besonders gute mecklenburg vor vermisst
das musste noch gesagt werde sich wohl
wenn wir jetzt alle nach mecklenburg
vorpommern kommen dann ist es mit dem
mindestabstand vielleicht auch nicht
mehr so ich dort würde ich dann sicher
auch noch was einfallen riesen
missverständnis sagte helge braun auch
der bund will eigentlich dass ihr
vorschlag angenommen wird frau schwesig
sie sind damit auch nicht allein
woran hakt es jetzt noch also noch mal
die frage
er stand da auf der leitung und hat
verhindert dass es einen eine solche
konkrete verschärfung gibt also es war
ja zunächst seine beratungen im
kanzleramt bei herr braun mit den chefs
der staatskanzleien und ich hoffe sehr
dass jetzt alle oder viele jetzt
einsehen so kann es nicht bleiben
und wir reden weiter drüber und deshalb
hoffe ich dass jetzt eine lösung kommen
ich kann nur sagen es ist genauso wie im
letzten jahr und das ist etwas was ich
auch nicht verstehe im letzten jahr hat
mir die gleiche diskussion
es ist auch nichts passiert dann hatten
wir die möglichkeit als land selbst
diese regel einzuführen wie haben sie
eingeführt werden hatte schleswig
holstein nachgezogen und dann guides
irgendwann deutschlandweit jetzt ist
unser problem
wir dürfen sie als land nicht selber
einführen weil nur noch der bund
zuständig ist so viel zum thema ist es
besser wenn es der bund macht nicht nur
den den hinweis auf das wunderbare
urlaubsziel mecklenburg vorpommern
richtig von dem was frau schwesig ich
gerade gesagt nach italien für mich
richtig ja ja ist ein schönes land
aber ich finde auch den hinweis richtig
auf pcr test und fünf tage weil das
praxistauglicher ist zehn tage jetzt ist
eine sehr hohe hürde auch bei
notwendigen reisen
ich glaube das ist besser und ein
verpflichtender tele 5 tage der anteile
dann würde die erde wenigen und würde
sagen dass es zumindest wäre ein guter
debattenbeitrag mehr wissenschaftlich
abgestützt werden insofern reden jetzt
politisch wohl auch wissenschaftliche
expertise nötig ist und darüber hinaus
wäre das doch eigentlich jetzt der
richtige anlass um innerhalb der
europäischen union über diese frage zu
sprechen
also es ist ja nicht nur ein problem
schwerin oder oder in deutschland
sondern es ist ja ein thema das alle in
der eu angeht und deshalb wer die die
bitte und der rat an die bundesregierung
telefonhörer in die hand nehmen
brüsseler anrufen im europäischen rat
eine gemeinsame linie finden wir haben
den impfpass den digitalen seiten aber
die lage hat sich ein stück verändert
also brauchen wir auch eine gemeinsame
herangehensweise
ich glaube das würde die portugiesen
auch schätzen
so und jetzt haben wir von der
bundesregierung niemanden hier aber
gehen davon aus dass die das sicherlich
schon mal schwierig und naja das ab und
zu die vorschläge ich mich gleicht sich
durchsetzen aber so war es auch im
letzten jahr was wir uns wünschen ist
sie haben recht herr lindner so müsste
man es jetzt machen aber was wir uns
wünschen als land ist wenn es ihm zu
lange dauert das wir dann wieder selber
als land handeln können denn ich will
mal sagen die bewertung der in mv haben
genauso wir in ganz deutschland alle
einen hohen preis bezahlt es war so ein
langer herbst und winter ist es alles
was sie hier schon gesagt haben die
kinder jugendlichen die die wirtschaft
alles war kultur sport also wir sie
atmen jetzt auf dass es wieder eine gute
lage ist und wir müssen alles dafür tun
dass wir nicht wieder zurück kommen in
eine lage die sehr kritisch wird wir
müssen schließungen vermeiden dazu
gehört nicht nur die reiserückkehrer
frage die man jetzt einfach besser
absichern kann wir haben wir heute die
methoden von tests sondern dazu gehören
nimmt auch weitere
vorbereitungsmaßnahmen wir haben zum
beispiel ein neues ampel system
eingeführt in dem nicht nur die inzidenz
sondern auch die krankenhaus belastung
und impfquote eine rolle spielt und
schon klar geregelt dass wenn die ampeln
wieder hoch gehen also nicht auf grün
stehen dass man ihn wieder stärker tests
einführt wir müssen uns mit dem mix aus
impfen und testen schützen aber ich will
auch sagen das allerwichtigste ist dass
jetzt alle bürgerinnen und bürger die
sich impfen lassen können auch das
angebot annehmen da haben wir auf jeden
fall dass wir hier reden von gut und
schön das ist das wichtigste
das ist ganz interessant ist der nächste
punkt ich möchte nur von frau federle
nochmal ihre erfahrungen des letzten
sommers türen federle im grunde hängt ja
jetzt dann an der reisefreudigkeit der
urlauber muss man sagen wie gut oder wie
schlecht deutschland da steht glauben
sie dass es ein neues verständnis dafür
geben wird wie weit es im letzten sommer
also im letzten sommer hatte ich das
gefühl dass die regierung auch pause
macht zumindest was bei uns im ländle
sozusagen und es wurden wenig
vorbereitungen getroffen um ganze land
werden
ich bin wirklich komisch angeschaut
worden als ich gesagt habe ich bereite
mich gerade auf die zweite welle
vor und wir müssen testsysteme
organisieren das war auch der grund
warum wir dann den tübinger warum ich
diesen weg gegangen bin hier haben wir
ganz ganz früh angefangen zu testen und
auch einfach so band systeme aufzubauen
dadurch wir haben ganz früh gesehen aha
da passiert was und dort passiert was
und die zahlen steigen oder sinken
und leider ist es nicht aufgenommen
worden damals und ich glaube aber auch
dadurch dass die regierung das an sich
genommen hat und dann entschieden hat
dass das bundessache ist und nicht mehr
ländersache übrigens danke nochmals sie
haben wir dagegen gestimmt
ich bin es nicht gemacht
dieses modell als heißt unser modernes
obwohl es erfolgreich war obwohl es
genau jetzt solche situation super wäre
weil es ist ja nicht immer zu erwarten
dass vielleicht überall wahnsinnig des
virus hochschnellt sondern dass es
bestimmte gebiete gibt und da wäre super
gewesen die zahlen wissenschaftlich
begleitet zu haben und das haben die
jugend und professoren genauso gesagt
unter anderem auch melanie brinkmann
was will ich sagen sie hatten
tatsächlich aber auch harte zeiten es
gab auch die aus anderen regionen aus
anderen städten thüringen ein reisender
schön die alkohol partys gemacht haben
ihr hattet ein alkoholverbot weil es
eben auch nicht die rücksichtnahme
achtsamkeit der leute gab die plötzlich
alle in tübingen sein wollte gut da muss
man sich halt vorstellen wenn ein halbes
jahr alles dichtes und niemand was
machen darf und dann ist tübingen das
einzige die einzige stadt in ganz
deutschland die offen hat dann war das
nicht anders zu erwarten dass alle die
kamen sogar aus holland und weiß gott
vorher nach tübingen ich habe aber
damals fand zum boris palmer ganz
schnell gesagt du hört zu wir müssen
hier dicht machen das geht nicht wir
müssen das kontrollieren
wir haben dann nämlich keine evidente
aussage weil wenn wir so überbevölkert
hindernis wäre es kein wunder wenn bei
uns die zahlen hoch gehen und wir haben
natürlich das war ja ein modell
wir haben anhand des modells auch
gelernt und es dann immer nachjustiert
und ich finds halt schade weil das wäre
für ganz deutschland wichtig gewesen so
was zu haben weil
und das glaube ich müssen wir uns
einfach alle klar sein wir werden mit
dem virus leben müssen und zwar auf
längere zeit und es wir reden jetzt hier
über delta vielleicht sitzen wir ein
paar monaten hier und reden über omega
und was dann verstehen sie richterin
über die bayern also das beste was
bedeutet aber als interessante aussage
lernen damit umzugehen und deswegen ist
zum beispiel das was vorhin auch gesagt
wurde was er jetzt auch über portugal
gesagt hat es ist auch ein wichtiger
aspekt dass wir das impfen total total
vorantreiben aber b auch die
hospitalisierung rate beachten und die
ist gerade mal also wir haben wirklich
kein problem jetzt bei der delta mutante
dass es so extrem ist dass die
krankenhäuser voraussichtlich wieder so
gefüllt werden sollten somit wird wenn
wir jetzt die britischen studien
anschauen dann ist es dann es ist ja
eindeutig dass nach einer zweiten
impfung bei bayern ticken schutz von 88
62 deswegen konnte jetzt auch diese neue
empfehlung des zu kombinieren und nicht
nur acht grad zu impfen und so weiter
aber das bedeutet die hospitalisierung
rate ist wesentlich geringer wie bei bei
früher bei der variante davor also das
heißt wir müssen doch viel mehr aspekte
auch besichtigen und berücksichtigen was
haben wir denn davon wenn wir wenn wir
die leute davor retten dass sie nicht
ins krankenhaus kommen und dass nur ein
geringer prozentsatz ist und auf der
anderen seite ein großer teil an
jugendlichen aber auch studenten
tatsächlich vor die hunde gehen und zwar
absolut nicht fühlt sich nicht so wir
ordnen frau rückstand und versuchen es
noch mal merken uns impfstoff müssen wir
auf jeden fall darüber reden und fangen
mit den mutationen an sie sagen wir
werden nach delta noch unendlich viele
mutationen sie
und wir müssen mit diesem virus leben
also da bin ich ihrer meinung wenn man
sich überlegt dass die welt im moment zu
zehn prozent durch geimpft ist 90
prozent der menschen sind nicht
geimpfter kann sich das virus ungebremst
ausbreitet oder nein
werden neue varianten unweigerlich
kommen ob sie nun aus brasilien indien
oder junaid kommen das ist dann auch
ohne karadzic eine schöne neue variante
ja also und deswegen hat man auch
begonnen die länder nicht mehr zu nennen
sondern alpha beta gamma delta zu sagen
das ist politisch korrekter war nicht
also ich gehe davon aus wir werden noch
viele varianten haben in einem punkt
stimme ich ihnen nicht zu dass wir sagen
die krankenhäuser sind nicht so
überlastet wie früher das ist zwar im
moment richtig auch in großbritannien ja
die haben etwa 300 fälle auf der
intensivstation waren aber vor einem
monat bei 100 jahre da sah das ganz
anders aus und die tendenz steigt weil
das virus wird ja nicht die leute primär
infizieren die zweimal geimpft sind es
geht in die einmal geimpften es geht in
die nicht geimpften es geht in geimpfte
die keinen guten schutz aus irgendeinem
grund aufgebaut haben und da kann das
natürlich als eine klare 1 für sein
unwesen wieder treiben aber ich sagte
aber wir sind ja in deutschland noch
nicht mal knapp 35 prozent doppelt
geimpft wir sind noch am anfang dieser
quelle mit jedoch wird die impfung
überhaupt zu halten ist voran 30 prozent
ihre konnte ich komme auf jeden fall
noch zum impfen ich schwöre es viele
konsequenz wäre jetzt erst mal zu sagen
solange wir noch diesen impfstatus haben
dass die menschen risiko geht hoch
risikogebiete mutationen varianten
gebiet am allerbesten zu hause bleiben
und sich klar machen dass sie das virus
schon hier haben sich entsprechend
verhalten masken tragen wo immer größere
ansammlung sind ich sehe wie lässig die
leute zum teil damit umgehen und das
halt ich so schön unsere zahlen sind und
alle sind natürlich heilfroh dass diese
sind und dass wir die gastronomie auf
machen konnten etc
ich denke wir sind in einer unglaublich
fragilen fragilen situation und wenn wir
nicht verdammt aufpassen dann haben wir
bald englische zahlen das hand da sechs
wochen gedauert und dann ist diese 5er
inzidenz sagen sie eben jetzt nicht viel
wert weil diese delta variante
hochansteckend ist noch mal die frage
von frau federle wissen wir dass dieses
virus in der mutation delta geht nicht
nur infektiöse sondern wirklich auch
gefährlicher ist letale dafür dass es
gefährlicher ist also mehr krankheit
verursacht oder auch mehr tot kenne ich
keine zahlen die das belegen würden
also ich glaub man geht im moment
zumindest es ist ja immer eine davon
ausgangen auch gleich weiß aber wie
gesagt das ist sicherlich 50 50 prozent
infektiöser als die alpha variante also
die sogenannte britische variante und
die war ja schon 50 prozent wieder
ansteckender als sie war ja früher auch
diese dramatischen zahlen nur an manchen
stellen zur verfügung gestellt in bezug
auf die erkrankung entschuldigen habe
mich ganz komisch ausgedrückt eigentlich
will ich sagen wann werden wir dann
wissen und hängt nicht davon viel eher
ab wie wir diese mutation einschätzen
müssen wie sehr sie die menschen krank
macht und ob sie sie sogar tötet weil
das doch eigentlich unser entscheidendes
kriterium
ich glaube das wird wenn jetzt die
nächsten wochen zeigen zum beispiel in
england wo und was ja fast
ausschließlich delta hat das heißt auch
die fälle in den krankenhäusern
wir müssen ganz überwiegend älter sein
und wenn man das ist mal ein paar wochen
oder 12 monate beobachtet hat kriegt man
glaube ich eine gute datenbasis und die
briten sind ja auch was die beobachtung
betrifft sehr gut also ich glaube schon
dass wir aus aus großbritannien da daten
bekommen werden relativ schnell bekommen
werden und sie sind in sorge dass die
gefahr oder besser gesagt die letalität
die mortalität diese variante größer ist
als der die wir kannten ist will ich gar
nicht sagen aber ich bin in sorge weil
sie eben ansteckender ist und weil ich
sag sind jetzt 300 patienten auf der
innenstadt intensivstation besser als
500 jahren natürlich sind die besser
aber es sind auch 300 zu viel denn sonst
kommt man ja irgendwann in eine
diskussion wie viel freiheit genießen
wir auf kosten von wie viele menschen
krank sind oder sterben und das ist
natürlich auch keine richtige diskurs
absolute sicherheit haben und ganz kurz
noch zu großbritannien
da ist sehr viel mit achim wurden viel
mehr als bei uns und eins ist klar und
unbestritten das astra als doppel
bei weitem nicht so schützt wie
beispielsweise und insofern kann man
nicht immer alles eins zu eins von jedem
land aus nächste land übertragen das
haben ja auch die daten überall gezeigt
zum beispiel ob diese lieder delta
variante letale ist das kann man
natürlich egal mit dem die geimpft
worden seien und dass sie irgendwie
krank werden die ersten studien zeigen
ja jetzt im moment zumindest ist es
heute auch bekannt gegeben wurden durch
ein professor märz soweit das eben die
letalität auch für kinder deutlich
geringer ist wie man gedacht hat ja und
ich finde auch wir müssen ein bisschen
hassen das einem anderen nicht so wenn
ich das aber nicht das war gott sagen
darf ich finde wir müssen aufpassen den
menschen brauchen auch einen irgendwo
noch ein ausblick ohne hoffnung und
zuversicht wenn wir ständig allen
menschen das gefühl geben bis sie wieder
kurz davor dass wir alles zu machen
müssen und ich bin die letzte die nicht
total vorsichtig ist glauben sie mir das
sonst hätte ich ihn nicht wirklich von
anfang an zum versucht zu beschützen und
wir haben alles dafür getan und ich
werde es auch weiterhin so propagieren
aber wir müssen auch aufpassen weil ich
kriege wirklich mit wie die menschen da
stehen wie es denen geht und das sind
nicht nur kinder und jugendliche das
sehen auch studenten die beispielsweise
beim ihren der praxis sitzen und sagen
sie finden keine psychologen mehr weil
sie alle überfüllt sind und sie haben
depressionen und teilweise auch in
anführungsstriche potenzielle tote das
muss man einfach mal sehen und wir haben
hier doch wir haben das glaube ich glaub
der der appell an die aufmerksamkeit die
lage zu beobachten das absolut richtig
und nach und im bergland vorzubereiten
und laden unsere halle insbesondere an
die politik sich vorzubereiten klar
teilen wir alles ich sehe auch dass wir
nach vielen monaten der erheblichen
freiheits einschränkungen und des
stillstands im gesellschaftlichen leben
an grenzen der akzeptanz stoßen man muss
das ganz offen aussprechen
die menschen sind irgendwann müde
gehört zu uns dazu dass wir gesellige
wesen sind wir wollen andere treffen
wir wollen unser leben führen der
deshalb ich zur vorsicht mahne dabei
jetzt wieder neu anzukündigen die
schraube anzuziehen wie ganz so habe ich
in den punkt zu ende machen der jeder
heimwerker weiß man eine schraube an
zieht nach ganz fest kommt ganz locker
weil die menschen sich nicht mehr daran
halten
privat ausweichen was könnte also eine
strategie sein
erstens sind wir hier einig zum impfen
gehört aber auch vorbereitung auf die
auffrischungsimpfung dritte impfung
gerade bei besonders gefährdeten
menschen bitte nicht erneut der fehler
bei besonders gefährdeten gruppen dass
wir sie vernachlässigen und da nicht
speziell gleich zu machen
zweiter punkt vernachlässigen befreier
bitte auch nicht dass wir auch
medikamente für diejenigen brauchen die
erkrankt sind also nicht nur forschung
am impfstoff ausweitung des impfen
sondern wir brauchen auch die
medikamentierung die behandlung die
therapie und der dritte punkt testen
testen bleibt ein wesentlicher
bestandteil einer krisenbewältigung
strategie war das erlaubt die stück
gesellschaftliches leben einerseits und
gesundheitsschutz andererseits da können
wir im herbst dieses jahres besser sein
als in der vergangenen messen wir und
werden wir unbedingt wir gucken nochmal
frau schwesig auf ihren vorschlag nur
damit wir das auch richtig verstanden
haben wie sollen denn jetzt verschärfte
einreise und auch quarantänebestimmungen
so sie denn kommen und sie sind
erwartbar umgesetzt und kontrolliert
werden wer kontrolliert an den flughäfen
in den bahnen an den straßen
das machen macht die polizei das macht
der herr seehofer schon mal nicht es
wäre aufgabe der bundespolizei noch mal
wir haben wir die gleiche situation im
letzten jahr gehabt und zum beispiel an
den flughäfen hatten wir dann die
entsprechenden aussteiger karten dann
gab es eine meldung zum beispiel in
unsere gesundheitsämter und unsere
gesundheitsämter da haben sich dann die
meisten bürger auch gemeldet oder die
gabe nachgefragt und dann ist verabredet
worden die quarantäne und das gute ist
ja bei der ganz geringen fallzahl die
wir gerade haben schaffen unsere
gesundheitsämter ist auch diese leute
zurück
also unser gesundheits und von ihren
leuten die in der quarantäne sind es ist
nicht so dass die sozusagen allein
gelassen werden und dann kommt ja noch
dazu
wer wir reden immer über die variante
aus einem risikogebiet zu kommen nicht
über die frage wie ruß mutanten gebiet
das noch mal was extra und dann kommt ja
dazu wer doppelt geimpft ist bräuchte
das ja in diesem umfang nicht
und noch mal ich finde zur ehrlichkeit
gehört auch dazu ich habe mich ein
bisschen gewundert als die lage
entspannter wurde und so getan wurde als
ob wieder alle fröhlich umher reisen
können zur ehrlichkeit gehört doch das
zurzeit niemand in der hand hat und
schon gar nicht wie hier in deutschland
wie es sich in anderen ländern
entwickelt und die frage ist ob das
wirklich gerade in dieser zeit seien
muss oder ob wir uns nicht auf stärker
auf das konzentrieren was jetzt bei uns
im land wichtig ist wie wir uns
vorbereiten nicht teile des wir brauchen
weiter die zuversicht
es darf nicht wieder zu einem lock down
kommen sondern wir müssen die zahlen
weiter niedrig halten kontakte
nachvollziehen brauchen ein neues
ampelsystem mit krankenhaus belastung
und im fortschritt müssen die impfung
voran bringen also wir alle sind sehen
werde
dann sind wir jetzt bei der impfung und
ich zitiere ihn einen ihnen nicht ganz
unbekannten rostocker oberbürgermeister
klaus ruhe madsen frau schwesig der sagt
der alltag für ungeimpfte müsse
unangenehmer werden
hat er recht stichwort die menschen die
jetzt noch nicht geimpft sind sollten
wir tatsächlich vermehrt dahin bringen
dass sie sich impfen lassen
das hat man so die impfung muss auf
jeden fall freiwillig bleiben und ich
glaube schon dass wenn man das
gefährdungspotenzial realistisch
darstellt wie sie frau schwesig auch
gesagt hat dass dann viel mehr menschen
auch einsehen dass ich mich besser
impfen lasse die vielleicht noch
gezögert haben und sicherlich kann man
auch kampagnen machen das haben wir auch
in usa ist das passiert da hat man sogar
zum teil und dollar ist ein vielleicht
soweit also in der kammer da kann man
auch ein bisschen kreativität walten
lassen um die menschen eben ans impfen
heranzuführen und ich muss noch mal
sagen man wenn man sagt die engländer
haben jetzt ein problem ja das liegt
aber nicht nur im stopp das liegt eben
daran dass nur
60 prozent der bevölkerung geimpft 47
eben nicht wir müssen mit dem level
insgesamt höher kommen und auch in
israel sind 60 prozent mit bier und
geimpft worden und auch die kriege ist
das problem trotz biontech ja auch die
haben noch 40 prozent die nicht geimpft
sind ich glaube da da müssen wir daran
arbeiten
da ist wirklich viel mehr menschen die
impfung so schnell wie möglich bekommen
nun hat die stiko erstaunlicherweise
reagiert sie haben schon erwähnt federle
da gibt es heute die vorgezogene
zweitimpfung das ist von vielen menschen
empfohlen worden ein paar ideen sitzen
hier jetzt hat es also die stiko so
entschieden nach astrazeneca mindestens
abstand hier wochen und dann den
impfstoff zu geben
was heißt das jetzt aber beispielsweise
für sie und ihre praxis die sind auch im
ärztin er ab wann können sie das
umsetzen was machen sie jetzt mit den
verbliebenen astra dosen also wenn ich
ganz ehrlich bin habe ich das schon die
ganze zeit so gemacht haben ich habe den
patienten immer geraten wenn sie mit
abstraktem strand sind im zentrum das
sich anschließend mit warmem tee kämpfen
lassen oder mit einem impfstoff
weil meine letzte devise als ärztin war
immer die ich würde ihm raten patienten
auch das raten was selber machen würde
und deswegen habe ich das auch damals
gesagt ich bin absolut ihrer meinung wir
müssen impfen impfen impfen
ich glaube auch und die erfahrung habe
ich gemacht dass sehr viele patienten zu
mir gekommen sind und ich werde auch von
übrigens aus ganz deutschland von
menschen angeschrieben die misa die welt
noch jeder lehrgang sind im rat geben
wer mein hausarzt hat gesagt er weiß es
nicht oder kennen sich nicht aus und so
also ich glaube da fehlt noch doch noch
ganz schön viel an aufklärung und essig
habe die feststellung selber gemacht
wenn ich mit den mit meinen patienten
beispiel rede dann kann ich die durchaus
auch davon überzeugen indem ich eben
sage genau das was ich gerade gesagt
habe ich habe mich auch im verlassen
oder genommen und dann kriegen sie auch
die menschen dazu auf eine linie immer
querulanten das wird immer so sein aber
dann werden die auch krank und nicht
treffen auch sie haben schon eine gute
sache jetzt gemacht und dem
für geworben haben auch sie haben das
gefordert dass es einen verkürzten impf
abstand gibt kommt es jetzt zu spät
kommt es gerade richtig
gott nach wie sie frau immer so sachen
dienen und nach rückwärtsgewandt sind
kritik was vor drei monaten hätte
passieren nicht gehabt die empfehlung
gut dass sie redet er hat schon gemacht
gut dass es jetzt da ist aber zu mir
gehört nicht also ich neige nicht dazu
das zu kritisieren was im vergangenen
jahr falsch gemacht worden ist oder
letzte woche war es kann man ja nicht
mehr ändern sondern nach vorne gerichtet
gut dass das jetzt da ist und jetzt
gehen wir weiter jetzt müssen
vorbereitungen getroffen werden auf die
auffrischungsimpfung medikamentierung
habe ich angesprochen test strategien in
den schulen
juli testet es kann ganz viel gemacht
werden
angebote für kinder und jugendliche
entwickeln
da haben wir jetzt aufgaben und ihre
auch in der tat die frage der werbung
und der aufklärung dafür es ist immer
noch wichtig die zahlen gehen runter
bitte nehmt den zweiten impftermin war
was ich höre was mir geschrieben wird
von praktikerinnen und praktikern im
niedergelassenen bereich wie hoch die
quote der abgesagten termin ist kann das
vielleicht sagen und sich am ende dafür
sehr prozess ist zum 100 das ist ja sehr
das kann dann ja nicht genutzt werden
für andere in der regel weil es zu
kurzfristig kann man diesen also wie
kann man diese im geschwindigkeit jetzt
noch anheizen
ohne zu sagen wenn du nach malle fliegen
möchtest dann musst du dich in das ist
der vorschlag von klaus gruber madsen
also man muss es zitat für ungeimpfte
unangenehmer machen
sie sich nicht impfen lassen ist es eine
variante das ist nicht mein menschen ist
nicht immer das sein es wird unangenehm
für leute wenn sie sich nicht impfen
lassen
da muss man jetzt gar nicht selber den
druck machen das wird unangenehm denn
die delta mutante wird sich ausbreiten
ich glaube das bestreitet ja kein mensch
mehr wer sie ist nach wie vor gefährlich
und deshalb glaube ich ist das beste
überzeugungs argument nicht der druck
nach dem motto wenn du dich nicht impfen
das tust du a und b nicht sondern das
beste ist dass wir den weiter den leuten
sagen
es fühlt sich gerade sommer leicht an
aber dieses droht dass sie sich
infizieren und sie können sich selber am
besten davor schützen und wir müssen
jetzt eine sache ehrlich sagen bis vor
kurzem hat die bevölkerung auch in
meinem bundesland jeden tag gehört dass
wir nicht genug impfstoff haben für die
die sich impfen lassen wollen wir hatten
jetzt wochen lang das problem dass wir
nur zweitimpfung machen ich kenne euch
noch erinnern können und erst mal müssen
wir wirklich um zwischen und sagen leute
jetzt ist es so kommt vorbei wir haben
jetzt genug impfstoff das ist ja jetzt
erst mal wirklich was richtig positives
stimme und natürlich dürft keiner
nachlässig werden und jetzt können wir
endlich auch den zweiten schritt zünden
den wir bisher gar nicht machen konnten
weil wir gar nicht genug impfstoff
hatten
und zwar dass wir wirklich sagen ich
nenne es jetzt mal salopp happy hour
kommt von 18 bis 21 uhr räubern gekommen
ihr werdet geimpft wir fahren raus wir
machen jetzt an unis noch mal extra
aktionen wenn man haben schon die ganze
ernährungsbranche haben wir ein großes
cluster da haben wir schon in fraktionen
gemacht also wir müssen jetzt mit dem
impfstoff zu einläuten also ich würde
sagen dass sie sich damit einfach machen
besorgen ausgelegt
richtig gas gegeben wird es ist ja ein
richtiger hinweis die menschen müssen
auch verstehen plötzlich haben wir
tatsächlich wirklich viel da und können
für impfen nicht nur erst sondern auch
zweikämpfen
wer es in brennpunkten sogar ganz schlau
für rücknahmen chef auf johnson &
johnson zu gehen eben weil dieser
impfstoff nur einmal noch nicht warum
nicht noch mal rein so langsam und dass
man eben in brennpunkten gezielt im teil
die für eine absolut gute maßnahme gar
keine frage aber ich wollte eben noch
etwas sagen
dazu zu impfpflicht es gibt durchaus
viren gegen die man geimpft sein muss
weil man in bestimmte gebiete einreisen
muss zum beispiel gelbfieber und auch
wenn das nicht ihre hier soll ist eine
politische ansicht ist dass man leute zu
etwas zwingen muss sollte als ultima
ratio kann man das auch mal diskutieren
schreibt ich bin da gar nicht
ideologisch wir haben in deutschland
auch eine impfpflicht bei pocken gehabt
bei masern woher jetzt haben wir wieder
einen ja dass das sind abwägungsfrage
wie ist danach die eigene krise gewesen
er weiter ja nur in der jetzigen
situation in der angespannten
gesellschaftlichen lage würde ich
jenseits der medizinischen argumenten
psychologischen gründen aus
psychologischen aus
gesellschaftspolitischen gründen ab
raten bei der im vlet ich bin heute hier
durch die stadt gefahren und da ich
jemand mit seinem rollenden mahnmal
gefahren er hatte sein auto eingebauten
hat lauter masken auf das auto
aufgeklebt und hat den kennzeichen
übrigens aus südwestdeutschland
unterstand darauf rollen das mahnmal
gegen die impfung gegen die masken
pflicht und das ist natürlich eine
absurdität nicht war aber trotzdem meine
ich bevor wir über solche pflichten
nachdenken oder solche worte wie wir
müssen es unangenehm machen
es ist eine fragile gesellschaftliche
situation ist eine gesundheitlich
fragile situation
es ist auch gesellschaftlich eine
fragile situation und deshalb nutzen wir
sie alle anderen möglichkeiten so haben
wir es eine nächste große frage sollten
wir kinder und jugendliche in das impfen
einbeziehen oder vor allem die
jugendlichen darüber ist viel gestritten
worden
große länder dieser erde machen dass die
kanals ja genau auch israel und wir
haben vor dieser sendung den chef eben
jene stiko jede ständigen impfkommission
in deutschland thomas merkens gefragt
warum es dazu eigentlich noch keine
empfehlung der stiko
wie gefährlich ist die delta variante
für kinder und jugendliche wenn man die
daten sich genau anschaut dann kann man
eigentlich nicht finden dass es einen
hinweis darauf gibt dass die delta
variante zu schwereren
krankheitsverläufen bei kindern und
jugendlichen führt wann wird es möglich
sein eine impfung für kinder und
jugendliche zu empfehlen
die altersgruppen müssen wir auseinander
halten weil für die kinder unter zwölf
jahren gibt es ja noch gar keine
kontrollierten studien und die sind erst
im gange und angekündigt als ergebnis
angekündigt da muss man also sowieso
noch warten bei den jetzt zugelassenen
impfstoff für die altersgruppe 12 bis 15
jährigen
da werden wir ungefähr noch drei wochen
drei bis vier wochen brauchen um auch
die ergebnis zu erhalten die jetzt
gerade die frage der möglichen
nebenwirkungen dieser altersgruppe
endgültig klärt welche rolle spielt das
ziel herdenimmunität natürlich wissen
wir dass wenn man die kinder und
jugendlichen nicht immer ist es dann
vermehrt infektionsfälle geben wird aber
die auswirkungen auf die
hospitalisierung sowohl in dieser
altersgruppe auch als sind in der
gesamtbevölkerung
und auch der todesfälle es eher gering
also bisher
und das war ja eine der grundlagen
unserer entscheidung ist die auswirkung
der generelle impfung aller gesunden
kinder in dieser altersgruppe auch im
weiteren verlauf in deutschland gering
frau riebsamen chef würde sofort wieder
sprechen hat sie schon gesagt ich würde
nur trotzdem einmal zwischendurch noch
nach schwerin fragen
frau schwesig würden sie was soll man
als eltern da entscheiden würden sie als
mutter ihren 14-jährigen 14-jährigen
sohn jetzt impfen lassen
ja ich stelle mir die gleiche frage wie
alle eltern und das ist dann schon
schwierig wenn dann so gesagt ja das
müssen die eltern die kinder ärzte
entscheiden ich kann sagen wozu das
führt mir geht es sicherlich sowie
vielen an
müttern und vätern auch wir haben waren
eigentlich offen für die impfung unseres
14 jährigen sohnes und haben die
kinderärztin gefragt die auch die dann
sagt also bisher hat für sie immer die
empfehlungen der stiko gezählt und sie
rät jetzt auch noch zuwarten und ich
glaube in dieser warteschleife befinden
sich viele eltern und das ist offen
gestanden kein gutes gefühl dass tiere
die arbeit des tea co
aber ich habe die vorstellung wir sind
geimpft als eltern dort wird geimpft
aber wir können nicht viel für unsere
kinder tun und das ist kein gutes
gefunden wären wir im weiteren schritt
sofort wieder bei christian lindner und
den schulen vorher fragen wir vor
rücknahmen chef nach genau diese
geschichte karl lauterbach sagt
unbedingt kinder und jugendliche impfen
aus 1000 gründen kinderärzte reden
dagegen und sagen das ist alles verfrüht
und wir wissen bei den jungen
jugendlichen dass sie eben nur in einem
niedrigen prozentualen bereich erkranken
was sagen sie ja das ist schon richtig
dass jugendliche geringer häufig
erkranken als erwachsene und ältere
menschen aber man darf nicht vergessen
das sind ja gerade ist er gerade eine
gruppe der bevölkerung die viel kontakt
hat und viel von diesen infektionen dann
auch in die familien zurück führt
deswegen hat ja sogar die stiko geraten
dass man auch ein gesundes kind jetzt
schon impfen sollte wenn in der familie
zum beispiel ein opa ist der risiko hat
nicht also deswegen widerspreche ich dem
dass die nicht auch ein motor sein
können für das weitere ausbreiten des
virus und ich persönlich wäre aus dem
grund dafür doch jetzt zu impfen weil
ich glaube nicht wir haben das denn viel
zeit haben und weniger kinder wie immer
mehr erwachsene müssen wir impfen und
die vereine fragen sollten kinder impfen
weil wir eigentlich erwachsene schützen
wollen neuwahlen schützen wollen die
kinder seien ja das hängt das hängt ja
zusammen wir müssen vor allen dingen ja
dafür sorgen dass wir nicht im herbst
neuer einträge in alten- und
pflegeeinrichtungen und bekommen bei den
menschen lieben größtes gesundheitliches
risiko haben schwerer krankheitsverlauf
während ammonit schon wieder sind und es
hat dritte stichwort dritte impfung im
fenster in dem bereich immer zu den
schulen frei
ich bin ein bisschen unruhig mit blick
auf die schulen wir versichern uns alle
ja bloß nicht mehr die schulen schließen
und so weiter sie glauben und ich
wünsche mir dass es so kommt aber ich
bin dennoch unruhig wenn ich sehe dass
die konferenz der kultusministerin und
kultusminister der länder also die für
die schulen zuständig sind sich das
nächste mal planmäßig im oktober treffen
da werde ich unruhig da würde ich würde
ich würde raten die kommen jetzt
zusammen die sollen liegen ja aber wir
sagen sie sollten jetzt zusammen kommen
um zu beraten was ist zu tun
ich kann verstehen dass die stiko noch
drei wochen braucht ich bin auch da
ungeduldig aber meinetwegen wir haben
jetzt sommerferien sollen die noch
treiben
aber gleichzeitig muss doch nur logistik
aufgebaut werden das am ersten schultag
in der ersten schulwoche ferien den
schulen nicht nur tests sind sondern
auch mobile impft teams nie ein angebot
machen und die schülerinnen und schüler
wo eltern und auch die schüler selbst
sagen ich möchte geimpft werden wo das
dann möglich wird ja draußen geräusche
sagen sie auch das ist eine gute idee
auf kinder und jugendliche zu erweitern
vor allen dingen auf die jugendlichen
die wollen also ich bin im moment noch
vorsichtig und zurückhaltend weil ich
auch glaubt dass die studien noch nicht
genügend aussagen deshalb sage ich ja
das kann man ja noch das war ja aber
natürlich keine frage wenn es dann
genügend daten gibt ist es für mich gar
keine frage wir müssen 1 uns auch klar
sagen wir haben so viele dinge falsch
gemacht in der pandemie und wenn jetzt
was schief läuft wenn wir kinder impfen
ja und nehmen das empfehlen und es ist
nicht aus irgendwelchen gründen gibt es
doch schwierigkeiten ja oder nicht
er ahnte risiken wie bisher auch bei den
erwachsenen immer mal wieder vorgaben
dass es risiken gab dann machen wir uns
wirklich auch an den kindern schuldig
weil wir impfen die kinder nämlich um
uns abzusichern
warum sie aber in erster linie ums ab
diese können die rotes rate der kinder
als in baden-württemberg ist ein
einziges hat wir haben die sommerferien
und ich sagte ja ferien abwarten
wissenschaftliche expertise logistik
auch wir müssen hilft teams ich bin auch
mit den mobilen impf teams das ist gar
keine frage dass wir die unbedingt
laufen lassen sollten ich glaube nicht
dass wir diese turnhallen noch zu lassen
sollten als im zentren weiterführen wir
sollen das alles an die hausärzte die
fachärzte die betriebsärzte geben ja
aber von mir aus auch an die apotheken
habe ich kein problem mit da in anderen
ländern in apotheken
aber wir müssen für die schulen wirklich
was finden wo die abgesichert sind wo
die anfangen wo das lüften nicht wieder
her stimmt unterricht wo die bill und
wenn man nicht richtig lüften kann dass
man dann eben eine belüftungsanlage rein
macht kann man darüber diskutieren was
man bisher noch nicht getan hat wenn wir
nämlich tatsächlich mit dem virus über
längere zeit oder über lange zeit leben
müssen mit mutanten und und dann müssten
wir vielleicht auch irgendwann mal
darüber nachdenken ob wir vielleicht die
sommerferien verkürzen und dafür die
winter stehen verlängern
dann haben wir nämlich in den
sommerferien wo es sowieso warm ist sind
die kinder er in der schule und in den
winterferien wo unter umständen durch
die kälte einfach des virus sich viel
viel mehr ausbreitet sind die kinder
näher hin hause genau interessanter
vorschlag vorschläge kurze frage ganz
kurze klare frage wie viele schulen in
mecklenburg-vorpommern haben schon einen
neuen luftfilter wir haben uns
vorbereitet bei uns beginnt die schule
schon ab august
und wenn alle denken dass man draußen
rum schule ist alles egal hauptsache in
der schule kann alles mit wir gegen das
virus getan werden da fängt unser
problem an ich will das noch mal ganz
deutlich sagen die situation für kitas
und schulen entscheidet sich danach wie
die situation außerhalb von kitas und
schulen ist und deshalb ist erstens
wichtig dass wir ein ampelsystem und
deutschland hatten noch mal was ich
musste sagen und zweitens würde ich
sagen wir natürlich wir brauchen keine
kultusministerkonferenz
wir haben es selber vorbereitet es ist
wichtig dass wir eine hohe impfrate
haben bei den erzieherinnen und lehrern
münchen gleich an lager das sage ich
ihnen gleich und da haben wir uns über
die stiko hinweggesetzt und die lehrer
und erzieher schneller geimpften und das
richtig dritter punkt das ist mir auch
noch wichtig wir brauchen am anfang der
schule testpflicht und nochmal maske
dass die ersten 14 tage weniger
urlaubsreisen rückkehrern und wir
brauchen entweder ein lüftungsgerät oder
ein luft ein diese dieses messgerät
unsere wissenschaftler in mecklenburg
vorpommern sprechen sich gegen die
lüftungsgeräte aus sie sagen dass echte
luft muss stattfinden
wir legen ein landesprogramm auf dass
die schulträger selber entscheiden wie
viele ist schließlich gerät oder das amt
oder diese das messgerät haben das ist
das thema bei den geräten das sollen die
träger selber entscheiden sollen die
träger entscheiden sie haben immer noch
eine zeit lang wird einen praktischen
vorschlag machen
zum ersten august in vier wochen muss
die bundesregierung aus den experten der
stiko und epidemiologen und kinderärzte
nein vorschlag vorlegen was es in den
letzten vier wochen an erfahrungen
gewesen mit der mutante in britannien
und portugal und israel bei kindern was
es an erfahrung führen die impfung aus
den ländern und müssen wir impfen
frau schwesig ich warte immer noch auf
die zahl mache ich dann vielleicht in
der nächsten sendung und vor allem chef
sagt uns noch wie groß ihre sorge ist
dass wir so ein lockdown noch mal nicht
nur aus papier schreiben sondern ihnen
bekommen sagen wir so wir müssen aber
natürlich dass man das glaube ich hier
am tisch alle einig alles tun um ihn zu
vermeiden dass man aber in bestimmten
bereichen mal doch nicht drum rum kommen
zum beispiel wieder große familienfeiern
verbieten muss etc
das halte ich für absolut nicht
unwahrscheinlich warum soll deutschland
sich anders entwickeln sagen ich noch
mal als großbritannien wir haben sogar
noch weniger geimpft als so ein land und
wir haben das virus also ich hoffe ich
habe unrecht als verstehen sie mich
nicht falsch aber dass wir das ein oder
andere die ein oder andere reaktion auf
eine neue verbreitung haben müssen das
halte ich für wahrscheinlich und genau
das liegen sollte man sich über solche
maßnahmen unterhalten und nach unten
rechts möglich anfangen spätestens am 18
der jüngste vorschlag von frau schwesig
es gab eine menge vorschläge an diesem
tisch und ich danke ganz herzlich für
die diskussion
der abend ihnen fürs zu schauen und zu
sehen bei markus lanz ich spreche schon
wieder schneller sie merken es sitzen
heute unter anderem melanie brinkmann
karl lauterbach und stefan aust an ihrer
stelle würde ich dran bleiben wir sehen
uns nächsten donnerstag wieder 22.15
richtig
75 auch das ist korrekt und wir sehen
uns nächsten donnerstag wieder wenn sie
wirken gleiche stelle gleiche wenn es
bis dahin bleiben sie gesund bei
[Musik]